ولا يريد الاعتراف بالسلطه العائله
الحاكمه في المملكه
وتعرف مسمى السعوديه مسمى حديث يعني رسميا
انطلقنا في 23 سبتمبر 1932 لما الملك
المؤسس همم قرر ان يطلق اسم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ليوحد سلطنه همم
فهم الان همم لا يريد الاعتراف
بالهويه السعوديه ااه المعارضه الشيرازيه
اخذت اسهل اسم باعتبار من المملكه تمثل
المساحه الاكبر من الجزيره العربيه سمر
الجزائريين همم حزب الله الحجاز الاسم
خلاص راح عليه خلاص
افضل شيء ان هو مختاره المنطقه همم
وفي رمزيه اللي هي همم الطريقه
اسم طيب على المستوى الافكار والمنهج
والارتباط السياسي طبعا مختلف تبعه من ليش
هم يجمع بينهم عدم الاعتراف بالدوله
الوطنيه الفكره الاميه همم الشيرازيينهم
اقرب الى الاخوان المسلمين في الفكر
الاممي همم
والتمدد في بيئه قطيفه لان
صادفت ان في همم علماء شيرازيين جاوب
العراق
كبار
والحوزه اللي بالكويت اللي انتقاله
العبادين طبعا في اقليه شيرازيه راحت
الاحساء بس يضلوا اسماء بسيطه